bloopers are just a part of doing
business when that business is show
business
actors are bound to mess up a line every
now and then or after a long day on set
improvise and make their co-stars laugh
while most of these flubs and goofs are
innocence
some are downright raunchy for example
Full House has there ever been a more
innocuous TV show than full house the
often sickeningly sweet sitcom used it's
our track almost as often as its laugh
track but two of its cast members were
veteran stand-ups both quick on their
feet and even occasionally pretty filthy
in this blooper Dave Coulier really
let's Bob Saget have it but apologizes
to another character off-camera actually
how little your isn't that sued
patty I'm sorry Bob
we're sorry baby
friends the friends of friends were well
friends and when people are that close
both in friendship and proximity there's
bound to be the occasional bit of
accidental nudity it's even a plotline
that was actually scripted on friends at
least a couple of times but this is not
one of those times The Fresh Prince of
bel-air in this blooper from the
otherwise classy sitcom The Fresh Prince
of bel-air Colton is supposed to be
concentrating really hard
but he looks like he's doing something
else so somebody in the sound booth
sweetened the shot gotcha
the Soupy Sales show CP was a beloved
Kitty TV host in the early days of TV
but one day his crew surprised him in
the middle of a taping with an r-rated
special guest behind an on-set door
[Music]
30 rock Will Arnett's had a recurring
role on 30 rock as Devin banks a
nefarious and sometimes predatory NBC
executive with his eye on the innocent
page Kenneth his flirting could get a
little creepy and alarming such as when
he force-fed Kenneth a bottle of apple
juice and arnott's riffing got a little
too out of hand Michela thirsty there's
tea mal better off ted this quirky ABC
sitcom aired for just two seasons but it
quickly became a cult hit for it's
surreal and twisted take on office
culture in one episode a typo in a memo
requires rather than discourages
employees of the show's workplace to use
offensive or insulting language this led
to some pretty insane outtakes as the
actors and writers kept trying to one-up
each other he is just a sample and
terrible at insults I can help you you
Mouse humping pieces I can help you you
sweaty thong and a hookers money crack
could you repeat that in English I don't
speak the language of the square-jawed
puppets Parks and Recreation a
tremendous cast of comedy all-stars keep
things loose and improvise from time to
time on the set of NBC's small town
government comedy Parks and Recreation
but Chris Pratt in particular at a
difficult time not crossing the line
such as in this scene where the gang
pretends to be old people to better
empathize with them thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]